un extrait qui a suscité beaucoup de
réactions c'est celui là il a pris un
exemple qui a beaucoup fait rire les
internautes regardent et on va nous
reprocher d'être d'être d'être étonné au
départ de la france il ya des avions qui
font six sept heures de vol comme ça
sans masque pour manger parler
vous allez aussi en martinique oui oui
vous allez en martinique le vaccin mais
au théâtre
non alors que le théâtre on a le masque
on rigole c'est la seule le seul risque
de post it j'ai hâte que ça recommence
et puis ça devient vraiment physique
c'est à dire que j'ai besoin
physiquement d'aller sur scène coffre de
jouer de transpirer de mon corps mon
corps m'en parle souvent
c'est vrai que mon il sait il nous fait
rire avec cet exemple il sait qu'à plein
de gens qui sont en difficulté moi j'ai
du mal à en parler c'est vrai que c'est
un de mes meilleurs amis le ca ainsi si
voilà c'est vraiment donc je fais pas je
vais pas longtemps c'est parce qu'il
vous savez que l'on sent ce tour je
lancerai tous les soirs mais c'est vrai
que une fois de plus trouvé petit c'est
vrai qu'il ya un bon exemple vient de
nous faire rire mais moi quand j'ai vu
s'interroge été touchés parce que moi et
justement et m'a pas il m'a fait rire
sur l'exemple de l'avion qui est plus
que vrai c'est incompréhensible qu'on
puisse être dans un avion 8h et qu'on
puisse manger et qu'on puisse pas être
dans un cinéma donc son exemple est
super bien et c'est imparable exemple
est imparable
mais moi j'ai vu un gad elmaleh qui j'ai
d'abord j'ai découvert qu'au plus mal
quand il ya eu des accusations de on va
en parler au plus mal il à ses potes il
dit que c'est pas de proches ont été
médiocres et que ça a fait le ménage au
niveau de ses potes et ça mais c'est
vraiment le truc fort de savoir ça que
même gad elmaleh qui pensait avoir des
potes proches
ben il s'est fait et c'est manger des
carottes et il dit que sa vie a des
potes qui sont pas bien comportés
j'ai trouvé la métaphore comme l'igad à
chaque fois je dis franchement il m'a
dit et il a raison mais montrent bien
c'est que il me dit à chaque fois
lorsque j'ai eu mes difficultés et chez
ca a eu le mérite de faire faire le
ménage au sein de mes potes et au sein
de ce qui se disait proche de moi
regardez d'ailleurs il a parlé de ces
accusations de plagiat qui l'ont
beaucoup marqué il ya deux ans et un
youtube heures kobe comique qui avait
diffusé des extraits de gat qui
ressemble à d'autres ce qu est une
humoriste américain et pour la première
fois il est revenu dessus vraiment il
nous a vraiment expliquer le truc tu
regardes qu il est vrai que je me suis
inspiré de comics américains oui
est-ce que je les revendique et moi même
oui est ce que il m'est arrivé de
prendre carrément des formules de
certains mecs que j'admirais oui j'avais
l'impression que je découvrais un champ
des possibles obscur de l'humanité que
je n'avais jamais rencontré
parce qu'à une autre chose c'est que
vous vous voyez en façade les titres il
a fait d'affamer - en dessous j'ai les
gens du métier qui il ya une autre et
une autre vibrations il est une autre
attaque est une autre tension qui vient
s'ajouter à ça au quotidien
moi je trouve que cette interview est
bas elle est nécessaire à leinster pour
que les gens voient aussi que derrière
les artistes qui a aussi des êtres
humains
et ça je pense que c'est important que
ça concerne l'histoire du théâtre avec
par rapport à l'avion costa concerne la
les histoires de plagiat eh ben ça a été
dit avec humour avec douceur et aussi
avec blessures parce qu'on sent qu'il
est à la fragilité et réalisé énormément
et je trouve que c'est vachement
intéressant d'avoir enfin un artiste qui
se libèrent et qui dit les choses
calmement le de gueuler comme d'habitude
comme font d'autres personnes je redis
là où c'était vraiment nouveau dans ton
de gad elmaleh c'est qu'en fait il a
reconnu aussi ses erreurs mais hier
qu'il a reconnu sa manière de
communiquer au départ quand il a été
pris justement dans cette tourmente du
plagiat qui a été une folie pour lui oui
il explique justement des gens qui sont
détournés
l'ia les voiles qui sont partis il ya eu
le vide autour de moi c'est ça il ya
beaucoup de l'an 2000 sont très indécis
n'ont effectivement s'est dit qu'au
départ il a un peut nier il a été
maladroit dans sa communication et jeu
et je trouve que l'ajustement comme le
dit kelly il arrive de manière beaucoup
plus calme beaucoup plus douce apaisée
avec les gens et beaucoup plus humble et
voilà et je trouve qu'ils sont guéris
ctaq nouvelle diva est exceptionnel pour
aller le voir au lit et gâte moi je vous
raconter une anecdote à raconter ses
quinze jours donc au lieu
on l'accusé de plagiat on en a rigolé
ensemble 1 lors d'un dîner ou des tous
les deux je vous dis un mot manga des
mois ont dîné au pratiquement tous
toutes les semaines ou tous les soirs
ensemble pour faire un petit peu le
point sur ce truc là il c'est vrai qu'on
en rigoler et moi tu dis tu te prends la
tête pour rien franchement moi parce que
alors je vous le dis moi je suis le
spécialiste des tempêtes c'est à dire
des carnets améliorer une tempête qui
m'appelle sénat il a toujours eu plus de
nerfs
c'est là c'est vrai donc en gestion de
crise j'ai eu tout le monde je leur dis
à chaque fois regarde-moi égal on a eu
un mec exceptionnel je vous raconte
l'histoire aux téléspectateurs
c'est qu'il ya un mec un jour et vient
le voir mais cueilli dis moi j'ai vu ils
ont dit que jamais copié sur un mec j'ai
vu le mec et dis moi j'ai beaucoup plus
de routes ou gélules t magnifique mais
très dense qui dit qu'il a été lâché à
trimer par par ses copains qui ont fait
l'analogie avec vous seriez vous pouvez
dire ce soir quand il ya eu les affaires
ya deux trois ans avec ma famille on
sente ce sens et parler c'est vrai que
bizarrement le téléphone sonne moins
bien chez eux il ya des gens dont on
pensait qu'il pourrait dire un mot qui
lui qui ne disent pas et ça et c'est
vrai que moi j'ai vécu ici pour pour
d'autres énoncés avec dans ce métier
quand ça va moins bien
quand un côté un peu de vague côté un
peu de vent quand sa tempe est un peu
c'est marrant il ya beaucoup moins de
monde et ça c'est vrai que c'est valable
pour tout le monde qu'on soit autant aux
affiches ou même en bas